Es ist vielleicht nicht jedem bewusst aber mit eurem smartphone habt
Ihr einen wahren supercomputer in euren händen und da steckt so viel potenzial drin das waren es wissenschaftlich nutzen kann
Und zwar jeder und genau deswegen gibt es immer mehr projekte mit denen man durch die rechenpower des eigenen smartphones forschung
Unterstützen kann wie das genau funktioniert. Und was noch alles geht das alles. Und noch viel mehr jetzigen klicks und science fiction. Und
Tausend dank für diesen tollen themenvorschlag von euch auf den messengern also herzlich willkommen
Die idee an sich ist nicht neu durch den zusammenschluss von vielen rechnern smartphones und ihrer inzwischen
Extremen leistung entsteht ein supercomputer. Und was da zusammenkommt ist nicht gerade wenig heutzutage
Haben smartphones jahr, rund 1000 mal mehr leistung als der computer der
Apollo 11 im jahr 1969 zum mond geflogen hat und diese power kann tatsächlich sinnvolleres bewegen als elvis. Zu posten beispiel
dafür ist das projekt namens said at home das nach außerirdischen lebensform cd at home ist eine abkürzung für search of
extraterrestrial intelligence as rom und wurde 1999
Ins leben gerufen und auch hier stecken viele aktive einzelrechner dahinter im sommer 2013 beispielsweise
145000 rechner aus 233 ländern weltweit weil sie alle zusammen erreichten eine rechenleistung von
668 teraflops das ist richtig krass zum vergleich der zu diesem zeitpunkt schnellste supercomputer schaffte
33,86
Petaflops war auf dieser großartigen ideen basieren mittlerweile einige projekte zb die android app
Htc power to give die ebenfalls die rechenleistung
Zur, verfügung stellt die gerade nicht benötigt wird das selbsterklärte motto von htc im schlaf gutes tun
Denn den, berechnungen des unternehmens zufolge könnten eine million, htc one geräte zusammen, ein petaflop
Leisten damit würde würden sie es dann tatsächlich unter die top 30 liste der supercomputer schaffen
um die app zu nutzen wird empfohlen das netz anzuschließen
Und das smartphone mit dem wlan zu verbinden beispielsweise in der nacht damit die laufzeit nicht beeinträchtigt wird die nutzer selbst können
Dann, bestimmen für welches wissenschaftlichen projekt, ihre. Rechenleistung genutzt werden soll über die software bekommt das smartphone
Dann, datenpakete zugewiesen dass es berechnen kann. Zur. Auswahl stehen projekte die allesamt humanitäre
Und wissenschaftliche aufgaben erfüllen sollen das ist das ziel der idee beispielsweise kann man den
Hunger der welt bekämpfen oder krankheiten oder man macht sich damit auf die suche nach aliens auf der offiziellen webseite von
Heute sind sehr heißes hilft mit dass die welt nacht für nacht. Ein stückchen besser wird
Auch du wirst dann besser schlafen bisher gab es durch den. Zusammenstoß geballter rechenpower tatsächlich auch schon erfolge zu vermelden
das projekt
mythisches rights for the world project also übersetzt
So etwas wie nahrhafter reis für die welt konnte zum abschluss gebracht werden dass sie war es hier
Einen besseren reis ertrag, zu erzielen. Und zwar indem resistente reis stämme gezüchtet werden
Konnten viel rechenpower wurde gebraucht um die proteinstrukturen der wichtigsten
Reis stämme vorherzusagen ja in diesem kontext ist auch bank sehr wichtig diese software plattform namens berkeley open
Infrastruktur von network computing wurde an der universität berkeley entwickelt derzeit laufende rechnung mit denen
Ein genaues 3d modell der milchstraße erstellt werden kann sowie die simulation von protein- faltungen und vorhersagen zur klimaentwicklung
Bank ist auch nicht nur für android geeignet sondern auch die
Leerlaufzeiten von windows mac oder linux computern können genutzt werden als anwender installiert, man. Sich hier
Ein kleines programm und kann damit seine nicht benötigte rechenzeit auf mehrere projekte
Aufteilen wenn. Ihr kein video zu diesem thema und zu allen anderen dem verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp
Und in anderen messenger nur dann verpasst er kein video denn die abo box auf youtube die ist ja immer
Ein, bisschen lückenhaft über die messenger erfahrt. Ihr dann von mir. Noch vor allen
Anderen, vom neuesten video täglich garantiert da bekommt, er auch. Einen link zum disco server
Wo ich seit 19 fast den ganzen tag, irgendwo rum hänge einfach hier draufklicken. Und am besten auch mein schwesterkanal klicks
Um social media abonnieren da erfahrt. Ihr das neueste aus der welt des social medias aber nicht die
Genau, glocke vergessen und das in dem er hier drauf klickt, und hier geht es weiter. Dafür
Auch draufklicken der schnellste computer der welt bis dann
bleib dran